tras los esfuerzos para evitar un tercer
confinamiento nacional en manuel macro
vio reducida sus opciones con más de
5000 pacientes en cuidados intensivos y
las muertes acercándose a las 100.000 en
francia- el presidente alertó que el
país corre el riesgo de perder el
control una situación que ha obligado al
gobierno a cerrar las escuelas por
primera vez desde el final del primer
confinamiento el año pasado
guarderías y escuelas de primaria y
secundarias cerrarán por tres semanas
pero debemos preservar la educación y la
formación por eso se adaptará el
calendario escolar para que nuestros
niños no estén solos sin acceso a la
educación desde la próxima semana los
niños tendrán una semana de escuela
online y dos semanas de vacaciones de
primavera las medidas de confinamiento
que actualmente tienen varias zonas de
francia incluida parís se extenderán por
todo el país desde la noche del sábado
durante al menos un mes los ciudadanos
solamente tendrán que llenar un
formulario si van a viajar a más de 10
kilómetros de sus domicilios por alguna
de las razones autorizadas todos los
comercios no esenciales cerraran y se
insta a la gente a trabajar desde casa
macrón a rojo sin embargo un haz de luz
al final del túnel
anunció un calendario de vacunación con
el que pretende inocular a los menores
de 50 años a mediados de junio gracias a
las vacunas finalmente podemos
imaginarnos un final para esta crisis
nuestro principal objetivo es acelerar
el presidente también prometió un
calendario para una reapertura
progresiva de los restaurantes bares y
eventos culturales desde mitad de mayo
aunque el retorno a la vida normal aún
parece quedar lejos mientras los
franceses se preparan para unas semanas
difíciles